je sais que votre nom vous a parlé déjà
y'a pas trop ce que nous a dit d'aviron
là on a décidé de se séparer ou là je
vous aime toujours autant comme en tout
genre papa ça changera jamais pourquoi
tu me dises un papa c'est vous histoire
après quand tu reviendras mais je n'en
parle
du thon
j'étais là mentale sorte que tu les
aimes ça plus importants hors propos je
crois c'est passé pour nous vous passez
votre temps à nous dire que c'est pas
grave tout ça que rien n'a changé
des actions soit je peux parce que j'ai
des enfants j'ai vu plein de trucs avec
les arrêter avec les enfants très bien
qu'au monde isa présente antoine-antoine
ben oui bah oui le mont pas sur le vieux
port un antoine méo s'il te plaît tu à
respecter plan gauzès
je n'ai pas envie pcci mais parviendra
toujours je te marche
que la main
sont les enfants sera tess vous
l'accepter c'est qu'il va falloir cette
cabane un peu plus rigolo
toi pro qui n'ont pas eut cassé la
gueule dépend de lui
300 appartements les retraités c'est mon
père a divorcé trois fois jeté à corps